Gary and I are both from the Boston area
you grew up in Peabody yeah baby yeah
baby yeah and I had that I had that
accent kid dude bro immediately I think
you're mad at body Shh
god I don't like it I immediately just
associate that with like you can saw
that I was first you saw that I was
first in line to meet Carl your scrumpy
you came and got me ro kid bra guy they
loved the yeah yeah they can never call
you your name and there's this there's
this weird thing because they love Tom
Brady but they're also in love so they
always try to the men are very they're
like aw kid did you see Brady Monday
night wicked smart in a pocket kid like
desk-side and I'm not for not hot he's
hot I mean I'm I'm not gay enough but I
would love to take him to see wicked I
will get him to orchestra seats to see
wicked and maybe take him over to
Cheesecake Factory for a slice to spoons
I ain't gay
and then uh and then maybe take them
over to Barnes & Noble and just browse
just browse all the straight sections
you know one we're all go on Vietnam one
you know walk not not poetry not
literature and then I take them back to
my hotel room and just spoon them all
yes straightway just love to fill his
cleft chin with him mo sigh you know
just something there's the sweet
breakfast drink so glad you said mimosa
when does such a worse please I was like
we're on at midnight but take it easy oh
yeah yeah the question we have a mojito
yeah yeah you've got for later
we are kid yeah dude you were the first
comedy show I went to at the comedy
connection taste is so happy I know and
you and Bill burr were amazing and uh
you're still too my favorites but we
still quote things you said that night
me and my friend my oldest friend still
said and they were riffs really yeah you
went up and went milk milk you like milk
they had that big campaign it was it was
relevant at the time you what a got milk
campaign yeah and I said who who is the
demographic for this people unaware of
milk people oh that would go good with a
cookie MIT milk you say yes and then one
of my favorite heckling stories ever and
I'm so happy I know it's your story but
there were people talking I'll tell it
you do this better cuz I don't even
really do you and I did not come here to
be undermined and then you went shut the
gun and then oh I I didn't want to swear
did you see my lip quivered and we still
say that we go shut the up I didn't want
to swear my lip quivered oh yeah I
always get tightness in my stomach when
I have to confront these I'm not goin
tation on no you should be you're her
Gilliam and also kind of the modern
Tarzan oh thank you
together oh that's so nice yeah oh my
god I'm not you know felling your dimple
with mimosa but I love you
Gary Gotham everybody